es war einmal ein youtube kanal namens
schön schlau
[Musik]
hey ich bin mai und ich bin schön schlau
bzw ich war schön schlau fing alles an
mit einer weißen wand einem stativ und
einer webcam und ein paar freunden der
sonne der sonnenbräune der sonne heute
sonne
es ging um astronauten und darüber dass
sie im weltraum nicht trösten können
ohne zu kotzen wie ihr wisst schon
science unnützes wissen aber
wissenschaftlich erklärt dinge die ihr
euch vielleicht noch nie gefragt habt
dinge die euch vielleicht schon immer
gefragt habt was auch immer es ist
schreibt es in die kommentare wright es
in die kommentare wie immer in die
kommentare kurz sollten die videos seien
so kurz wie möglich ist sollte sich ja
keiner langweilen wir wollten auch
niemanden verschrecken ihr wisst schon
das 1 wir waren ein kleines team das
stativ melanie die grafikerin und ich
doch dann bekamen wir dann hier ein kind
und da waren es nur noch das stativ und
ich hunde waren noch die vielen anderen
sachen die ich auf youtube mache zum
beispiel musste wissen chemie und
außerhalb von youtube habe ich ja auch
noch ein job es wurde alles ein bisschen
viel
gleichzeitig war schön schlau inzwischen
ein jahr alt und ich bekam neue ideen
die freunde der sonne die mich schon
länger schauen haben vielleicht bemerkt
dass sie schön schlau seit beginn des
kanals ganz schön weiterentwickelt hat
einerseits technisch wie zum beispiel
meine ring leuchte die erstaunlich viele
leute irritiert andererseits inhaltlich
ich hab jetzt öfter bock auf lange
videos und manchmal auch lust mehr ins
detail zu gehen richtig ins detail doch
ab und zu habe ich auch mal lust einfach
nur albern zu sein manchmal will ich
auch ein bisschen spaß haben und die
wissenschaft auch nicht so ernst nehmen
unterm strich hätte ich einfach gerne
einen kanal die ein bisschen mehr ist so
wie ich als ganze person also ich bin
chemikerin und ich bin ein lied und ich
bin aber auch albern und ich bin
manchmal auch ein im hemd
[Musik]
außerdem möchte ich nicht mehr schön
schlau ist ein schön was ich mein ich
habe natürlich nichts dagegen schön oder
schlau oder sogar ganz schön schlau zu
sein nur sowohl schönheit als auch
intelligenz sind zu groß und teil
genetisch bedingt und wer schön und oder
schlau ist kann nicht so viel dafür
und wenn ich entsprechende komplimente
bekommen nämlich die gerne und dankend
an
danke mama und papa aber ich freue mich
tatsächlich noch mehr wenn ich zum
beispiel komplimente für meine locken
bekommen wir die ich mir mühsam ein
gedreht habe oder wenn ihr schreibt dass
ich mir so viel mühe gebe bei meint
videos oder wenn ihr findet dass ich gut
recherchiert habe lange rede kurzer sinn
ich konnte mich mit dem namen schön
schlau einfach nicht mehr identifizieren
und mit dem inhalt auch nicht mehr genug
also irgendwas fehlte um mehr zeit für
diesen kanal und meine neuen ideen zu
haben beschloss ich vor ein paar monaten
schweren herzens mit musste wissen
chemie aufzuhören
einige von euch hat mich auch schon
danach gefragt als hatte ich endlich mal
zeit neue ideen umzusetzen neue formate
zu testen
auch mal längere videos zu machen und
auch aufwendigere videos zu produzieren
schön schlau wurde zu einem
experimentieren da wo ein youtube
content lebt erste auswertungen deuten
darauf hin dass die freunde der sonne
dabei auch voll am start so viele neue
abonnenten mit denen ich gar nicht
gerechnet habe und danke und herzlich
willkommen und ich hoffe ihr seid
weiterhin am start wenn schön schlau ab
jetzt unter einem neuen namen läuft und
zwar weil mein leben verändert sich für
euch nichts ich lese immer noch gerne
eure kommentare mit euren
themenvorschlägen und jeden donnerstag
kommt ein neues video um 6.30 und bei
instagram und twitter erinnert sich auch
nichts doch nicht bei der name da bin
ich nach wie vor meist bzw
nächste woche gibt also regulär weiter
auf diesem kanal
mit allem was spaß macht ihr wisst schon
seien freunde der sonne wir sehen uns
nächsten donnerstag bis dahin leipzig